la prueba de detección de cáncer de
pulmón consiste en Buscar signos de
cáncer en los pulmones antes de que
aparezcan los síntomas la prueba puede
ayudar a detectar el cáncer en una etapa
temprana esto puede facilitar el
tratamiento ya que es posible que el
cáncer no se haya propagado se
recomienda hacerse la prueba de
detección de cáncer de pulmón una vez al
año si usted tiene un índice de consumo
de cigarrillos de 20 paquetes años lo
que significa que ha fumado
aproximadamente un paquete al día
durante 20 años o dos paquetes al día
durante 10 años actualmente fuma o dejó
de fumar en los últimos 15 años tiene
entre 50 y 80 años puede dejar de
hacerse la prueba de detección anual de
cáncer de pulmón si tiene más de 81 años
no ha fumado en 15 años o más tiene un
problema de salud que hace que no pueda
o no quiera someterse a una intervención
quirúrgica si se detecta que tiene
cáncer de pulmón la única prueba de
detección recomendada para el cáncer de
pulmón es la tomografía computarizada de
dosis baja también se conoce como tc de
dosis baja o tcdb una máquina de tcd
emite una dosis muy baja de rayos x que
genera una serie de imágenes detalladas
de los pulmones desde diferentes ángulos
una computadora utiliza las imágenes
para obtener una vista en 3D de los
pulmones y Buscar signos de cáncer si se
detecta tejido anormal Tal vez sea
necesario hacer otras pruebas o
procedimientos si tiene un riesgo
elevado de desarrollar cáncer de pulmón
hacerse una tomografía computarizada de
dosis baja podría salvarle la vida pero
hacerse una tomografía también implica
tres riesgos potenciales en primer lugar
puede dar un resultado falso positivo
esto significa que el resultado de la
prueba dice que tiene cáncer cuando en
realidad no lo tiene en segundo lugar
puede llevar a diagnóstico esto
significa que la prueba ha detectado un
tipo de cáncer que no es probable que le
causa ningún problema tanto un resultado
falso positivo como un sobrediagnóstico
pueden Conducir a otras pruebas o
procedimientos que usted no necesita y
pueden implicar otros riesgos y En
tercer lugar existe un riesgo muy bajo
de que hacerse muchas tomografías
computarizadas exponga a personas sanas
a una cantidad de rayos x suficiente
como para provocar cáncer por este
motivo la prueba solo se recomienda a
las personas con alto riesgo de tener
cáncer de pulmón
Si tiene alguna pregunta sobre esta
prueba o sus resultados consulte a su
médico